is to launch a set of publications that
have been developed
under the u and ncd interagency task
force
that call for urgent action on entities
during
and beyond the pandemic
first we call for the voices of people
living with ncds to be heard in all
discussions about policies that directly
affect them second we call for global
financing instruments to be extended to
low-income countries
that request support for
non-communicabilities
and third we call for constructive
uh dialogue or partnership with the
private
sector because people with ncds are at
high risk of severe covid19
finding effective therapeutics for these
patients is a high priority
earlier this week who issued issued new
guidance
on the use of corticosteroids to treat
patients with severe covid19
evidence shows that corticosteroids can
be
life-saving for patients on oxygen and
ventilators
however corticosteroids do not help
patients with mild or moderate diseases
and can be harmful who therefore
recommends the use of corticosteroids
only in patients who are severely or
critically ill these guidelines combine
the high scientific standards with the
urgency needed to respond to this
pandemic
providing guidance on therapeutics
diagnostics and vaccines is one
important part of who's work
ensuring access to those products is
another
in the coming months we all hope to have
good news about
a vaccine for covid19
but if and when we have an effective
vaccine
we must also use it effectively
in time as production increases
we want all people everywhere to have
access to vaccines
but initially when supply is limited
priority must be given to vaccinating
essential workers
and those most at risk
including older people and those with
underlying conditions
in other words the first priority must
be to vaccinate some people in all
countries
rather than all people in some countries
this is not just a moral imperative and
a public health imperative
it's also an economic imperative
in our interconnected world if people in
low and middle-income countries miss out
on vaccines
the virus will continue to kill and the
economic recovery globally will be
delayed
so using vaccines
as a global public good is in the
national interest of
each and every country
vaccine nationalism will prolong the
pandemic
not shorten it the kovacs facility
is the agreed international mechanism
for ensuring equitable global access to
vaccines
it is solidarity in action
kovacs guarantees access to the world's
largest portfolio of vaccine candidates
our partner the coalition for epidemic
innovation and
preparedness happy supporting
nine candidate vaccines that will be
made available to the
facility school seven of which are in
clinical trials we're also in
discussions about four other promising
vaccines
another nine candidates that are in
earlier stages of development are being
evaluated in the facility
we're delighted that 78 high and
upper middle income countries and
economies
have now confirmed they will participate
in the kovacs
facility and the number is growing
i urge those who have not yet joined to
do so
by the 18th of september
i would like to thank those countries
and economies who have
announced publicly they're joining
kovacs
this week germany japan
norway and the european commission
philandhang arigato gozaimasu
of course many more countries have
joined and we look forward to being able
to share
the full list in due course
although we still face many challenges
wha is encouraged by the progress
we have made against this new virus in
eight months
with national unity and global
solidarity
we can weaken and will end
this pandemic i repeat with national
unity
and global solidarity we can
and will end this pandemic i thank you
thank you dr tedros i will now open the
floor
to question from the press but i would
like to remind first
that you need to raise your hand use the
raise your hand
icon in order to get in the queue to ask
questions
also remember we have a large number of
you in the queue
so please stick to one question
um the first question is from
anias pedrero ajan
please emu to yourself and ask your
question anes
and yes can you hear me
and yes
we will come back to ajax france press
later on
now we have anna pinto anna can you hear
me
please don't forget to mute yourself
ana can you hear me
so we can have some technical problem
but uh trying again anna or agnes
can you hear me
so um if we cannot have agnes or anna i
will go to
gabriela sotomayor mexican journalist
gabriela
can you hear me
really
so let's see how we can fix this problem
sorry for that
um we are trying to fix the technical
problem
so let's try once again agnes
ifp
if you cannot hear me and speak please
type your questions
we will receive them thank you for your
patience
okay yeah
so um
hello gabriella anna agnes can you hear
me
if not we received a question from
um gabriela sotomayor from
mexico journalists from prosesso i would
like to know if you
agree with the call made by amnesty on
accountability and if you can say how
the rights of health personnel
can be protected they are exhausted
the pandemic continues it has not
stopped
how to help them many work in terrible
condition
and they are fired if they complain
so who will take this question dr maria
thank you yes thank you very much for
the question just checking if
uh people can hear us um so thank you
very much for this question gabriella
um you know healthcare workers are our
frontline workers and
and need to be cared for and respected
and protected
um for the incredible work that they do
uh on the front lines
um saving people's lives um from covet
19 and from many other
infections so all health care worker
infections are important even one health
care worker infection is
is too many so we have some information
on on health care worker infections by
country and it varies
quite uh it's variable highly variable
by country
um and from the data that we have that's
received um through our
our clinical platform through our case
report forms that come in
by country it's anywhere between 8 and
27 of the reported cases
from data from our regional offices this
week our regional director of pajo noted
more than 570
000 health worker infections in north
and south america
and in the u.s and mexico health care
workers account for about 14 percent
of infections across our african region
it's around 5 percent that are health
care worker infections
and if you look across the published
studies again the data is highly
variable
and if you look at seropositivity which
is evidence of infection through
antibodies um healthcare worker
infection ranges from
1.6 to over 31
depending on the study and if we look at
pcr testing by study
it ranges from 0.4 to over 23 percent
and so what we understand about how risk
how health workers are getting infected
there are several studies that are
looking at this and we have a living
systematic review that we are conducting
where we are constantly looking at the
literature
and some of the reasons why health
workers are infected is
because of a lack of ppe not having
adequate ppe to do their jobs
and in some situations not having the
training to wear
the ppe appropriately and early on in
the pandemic when we have
cases in some different wards such as
geriatric wars or other words that
weren't prepared for
droplet precautions for infectious
diseases
they weren't trained to wear the right
type of ppe that has been changed and
that has been improving
we also know that um health worker are
infected
while on the job when they're in rest
areas if
between each other so there's
transmission that's happening between
health workers
and we know that there are conditions in
which they are working and where there's
extended shifts not adequate rest
periods
that that really needs to be supported
but we also need to remember that health
workers are
people too and they live their lives and
unfortunately many health workers are
also infected outside of the health care
facility
so i think there's a number of things
that we are doing and that countries are
doing to protect health workers
um this is a priority of who's beyond
the pandemic but is a is a top priority
of who to protect health workers we have
guidance that is out around
infection prevention and control so how
they can care for patients safely and
the type of precautions that are needed
depending on the type of care that's
given
our supply chain task force has worked
very hard to ship
ppe to 172 countries in all regions
millions of respirators and mass medical
masks face shields
gowns gloves goggles we've issued
trainings
for infection prevention and control to
make sure that all health workers know
what this virus is
know how it is transmitted know how what
are the proper infection profession and
control measures that they can take
but we do need to ensure that health
workers are equipped with the right ppe
and i think just lastly we do need to do
more
to make sure that the right conditions
uh are in place for health workers that
they have adequate rest periods
that they have psychosocial support what
health workers are going through is
incredibly difficult
and we owe so much to them and i think
just very just lastly
we owe the respect to them and there
should be no stigma
attached to the life-saving work that
healthcare workers do
thank you very much dr maria we have
also in the room
dr um bruce elward he is the senior
advisor to the director general
he needs the act accelerator and he has
something to add bruce
thank you to fidella and thank you
especially gabrielle for
raising this important issue of just the
stress that the health care workers and
care workers and long-term facilities
continue to be under in this crisis
because
we cannot give it too much attention
quite frankly and i think maria has done
a wonderful job laying out all the
things that we're trying to do
collectively
through the health sector the health
organizations to try
and ensure they have the tools training
etc to
to take care of themselves but i think
what we have to remember gabrielle when
you ask what else we can do
is going back to what the director
general said in his opening comments
the single most important thing we can
do is to collectively
change our behaviors in the ways that
are going to reduce the
intensity of transmission reduce the
cases and reduce the pressure on the
health system
at the end of the day that is the most
important thing we do
we will look to our political leaders we
look to our health leaders to help
address these issues
but we also have to look to us
collectively the general population
how we choose to work how we choose to
live
how we socialize these are the important
things that drive
transmission we've got to ensure we
maintain the distance between people
the masks and the other public health
interventions because ultimately that's
what's driving transmission
that's what's putting the pressure on
the health care system but like you
emphasize most importantly
behind that system of people right it's
the health care workers the nurses it's
the
um it's the cleaners in the facilities
it's the it's the physicians and so many
others who work in these facilities
that pay the ultimate price for the
choices we make as individuals in terms
of doing our part
to reduce transmission that is the most
important thing we can do to help
thank you dr bruce edward we will go now
to
anias i i was told the technical problem
is sold
and yes franz press and yes can you hear
me
yes i can hear you ah oh do you well
and yes just ask your question
okay greg i will ask it in french
foreign
[Music]
is
thank you anias dr maria
i i can i can begin uh and maybe others
want to jump in
so you highlight a very important aspect
of
a pandemic or any emerging pathogen um
as as
this pandemic evolves there are deaths
that are associated that are counted
um that we know are associated with
coping 19 from infection
and are tracked in real time as they
occur there are ones that we will be
identified as we retrospectively look
at we go back in time and we look at uh
deaths and there are systems that are in
place
um in in several regions and several
countries that are looking at excess
mortality
um the one that i'm most familiar with
and there are others
is the one that that's in europe that's
the euro momo
project which is looking at excess
mortality over time
um and as you point out there are some
variations in
excess mortality by country um i think
it's too early to make
conclusions about this because this is
something that is ongoing
um but i think it is important to
recognize
that deaths from kovid are are likely to
be under counted at the present time
um but countries are working very hard
to better understand this
we do also need to be looking at other
causes of mortality
that are occurring during the pandemic
because people have not been able to to
access the care that they need
so it is really critical that we get
essential medical
services and life-saving services back
online
so that people who need the care that
they need can receive it
and can receive it safely um and so that
is something that all countries are
working very hard on we are working very
hard on to support countries to be able
to do
um but i think there we will see some
differences in excess mortality
and we are tracking the systems that are
currently in place uh that are
collecting that information
uh thank you dr maria uh dr benti
mikelson would like to add something
please go ahead
thank you thank you very much for the
question and
as dr tedroz said we have had several
uh surveys which show that we have
major disruptions
in the case of non-communicable diseases
cardiovascular diseases
cancer diabetes and respiratory diseases
so so far we have comorbidity studies
from single countries and we are working
on this also on a global level
so of course it will be very important
to
uh trace what you're actually saying
because we really need to know if this
will again
dwindle the achievement of the sdg 3.4
namely
to reduce the mortality from
non-communicable diseases so we don't
know this yet but
from studies we know and and the good
thing is that
the majority of countries have actually
now started to
register commodities in their hospitals
so
we know that for example in mexico
diabetes were the most frequent
comorbidity in the
registered deaths for koid and we see
other figures like in italy
among those dying in hospitals we see 67
percent of people living with
hypertension and 31 living with diabetes
so this is of course very important both
for the current situation
but also to understand the picture and
be able to
close these gaps with the guidance that
double aho can give
thank you
dr ross agnes you raised a really
important point about this excess
mortality data
um and as maria laid out the
many countries do track excess mortality
not all
countries so we don't have data from all
over the world
and as maria said it's actually tracked
differently in some countries so we
don't have exactly comparable data
but what we do know very very clearly
is that there has been more mortality
during this period
than the numbers from covet 19 alone
tell us
and that's extremely important some of
that excess mortality
is probably coveted disease that was not
recognized or reported
but then it's also telling us that this
incredible
impact on the health system that
gabrielle asked about earlier
is having a real cost in terms of human
lives
this all emphasizes the importance of
the measures that the director generals
just emphasize
day after day after day because there's
a real cost in human lives that go
beyond the numbers that we're seeing
in the coven numbers alone
thank you all for uh these uh answers
we will go now to india to uh uh
to ask haziz ahmad from hello mumbai
aziz can you hear me please unmute
yourself and ask your question
aziz
i was told he is no longer online if not
we will go to anna
pinto anna can you hear me
yes hi anna
just ask your question thank you okay
uh uh earlier this week the president
of brazil jair bolsonaro was approached
by a citizen
who asked him not to deploy vaccines
against
kovid 19 in the country because
according to him
and i quote vaccines are dangerous
and both of them replied to him that the
government
will not force anyone to get vaccinated
my question is i'd like to know what is
the who message
for people who believe that vaccines are
dangerous
and what can be done to counterbalance
anti-vaxxers movements
and this information thank you
thank you anna i believe this question
is for
dr sumiya swaminathan our chief
scientist sumiya you have the floor
thank you thank you padela and thank you
for that
very important question i think
this is really a topic that everyone
around the world is is discussing today
i think the first thing to remind
ourselves is that vaccines
are life-saving interventions and if you
think about diseases like smallpox
like polio like measles that used to
kill hundreds of thousands
and and made millions of people around
the world
it's thanks to vaccines that we don't
see those diseases today
we so we've forgotten what smallpox is
like we've forgotten what polio is like
we've forgotten how measles kills
you know used to kill millions of
children still does kill hundreds of
thousands of children unfortunately
around the world despite the fact
we do have a very safe and effective
vaccine for measles
so we have to put in perspective
you know vaccines and what they've done
for humanity
when we start thinking about covid
vaccines
we're at an early stage of development
no doubt
that there's been an unprecedented speed
of development
of covid vaccines we've never seen
anything like this before
and that's because of advances in
science and technology
and also the fact that there are now
platforms that have been
developed because of investments in the
last several years
which make it possible for companies
and academic groups to just take the new
virus sequence and put it onto an
existing platform which has already been
tried and tested for other diseases
and this is part of the reason why we
had a phase one trial of one particular
vaccine 66 days after the first genetic
sequence of this new coronavirus was
made public now having said that
vaccines still need to go through phases
of testing they need to go through
lab testing followed by animal studies
followed by
human trials starting with very small
numbers of people
to test safety moving on to what we call
immunogenicity studies where we look for
the development of
of protective antibodies and other
immune responses which we think
are signals but eventually you need
phase 3 trials
which actually look at reduction of
disease
in the group that's vaccinated compared
to the group that's not
given the vaccine or is given a placebo
and and this happens in tens of
thousands of people
who are also followed for safety signals
so no vaccine is going to be mass
deployed
before the regulators are confident and
and the governments are confident and
that who is confident
that these vaccines have met the minimum
standards of efficacy and safety
we have a very elaborate and thorough
process
where we look at all the criteria the
qualities of a vaccine
and whether they have been met before we
will make any kind of
recommendations either on emergency use
authorization or on a general
licensing or authorization for use
through pre-qualification
programs we have an independent group of
experts the sage
the scientific advisory group of experts
on immunization that makes
recommendations again it's a globally
recognized
independent group of experts that will
look at the properties of an individual
vaccine and the data from the trials
before they'll make a policy
recommendation so i think we should
reassure the public
that vaccines that are recommended for
use
by who and by the national regulatory
authorities
would have passed the minimum standards
needed we've also heard very encouraging
uh statements from a number of the
vaccine developers
and the heads of those manufacturing
companies that they will abide by
the standard guidelines and rules for
development of of
vaccines so there needs to be i think
the questions
that people are posing means that there
is a need for more information
sharing there's a need for more
transparency for more education of the
public
on vaccines in general and then on covet
vaccines
in particular thanks can i
yeah dr please thank you thank you for
dila
um i think um
some had said it all just want to stress
a bit i would like to
assure the public that double ho
will not endorse a vaccine
that's not effective and safe
so that's one and second
as she had said
vaccines have helped in
eradicating smallpox
then almost on the verge of eradicating
polio but i would like to remind the
world
how we used vaccines
to defeat ebola
in northern kibu eastern drc
where the
ebola outbreak situation was
effective and safe
that's what i would like to assure the
world
and as samia said this will be done by
wha and
local authorities as to
the anti-wax movement
they can build narratives to
fight against vaccines but
the truck record of vaccines
tells its own story
and people should not be confused
by a movement antibiotics movement
but they can have a look for themselves
on how the world actually used vaccines
to reduce under five mortality to save
children and
to have successful eradication
of this is like smallpox
so just please go to that to the track
record of
vaccines and have a look for yourselves
especially parents
have a look for yourselves and see
how vaccines actually change the world
and that's why we have this famous
saying
vaccines actually affect adults
our children will be healthy adults
when we use vaccines and for kovid
we are hopeful that we will have one so
that the world can
get back to normal thank you
you dr tedros we will move now to
simon ateba from
today news africa simon can you hear me
simon second attempt
simon we can hear you please go ahead
i can hear you thank you for taking my
question this time on a table from today
news africa in washington d.c
yesterday who africa said
virtually all african countries all 54
or 55
african countries have expressed
interest
in kovacs the groundbreaking initiative
to
provide almost 220 million
doses of vaccine to africa i would like
who to give us
an update on
what the next step is and what will be
the contribution of each
african country to take part in kovacs
and also to ask who if 220 million doses
of vaccine for
a continent that has 1.2 billion people
is enough thank you
thank you simon we will start with dr
bruce edward
bruce thank you simon and thank you for
emphasizing uh the importance of
the landmarks that we passed this week
in the
uh battle against covet and getting our
act accelerator up and
uh operating um as you highlighted
this week we passed the landmark by the
31st of august we were
asking countries to confirm their
intention to participate
in the kovacs facility and as the
director general highlighted we were
delighted to hear that 78 high and upper
middle income countries will be joining
with the
92 countries of of uh
gavi and that will receive support
through what we call the advanced market
commitment for a total
of now 170 countries that will be part
of the act
accelerator um the uh african continent
has
been a huge contributor to the work of
kovacs
as some people on the call will be aware
there have been a number of important
partners that we work with in terms of
trialing vaccines
and and studying vaccines also in terms
of planning how they would be rolled out
and operationalized over time also in
the very design
of the kovacs facility we've had a
number of big conference calls that have
involved
many of the countries that are now
signing up to covax
many many countries from the continent
who are providing their input
as we worked out the details of the
kovacs sicily and designed it
really together so a huge contribution
and and will continue to be as we go
forward
now in terms of vaccine numbers and
doses remember the way that we've been
discussing the use of these products
that will come out of the act
accelerator especially the vaccines
our goal our immediate goal is to reduce
the severe covid the burden of severe
covet disease
around the world because if we can
reduce the risk of severe covet disease
then we can very rapidly as a director
general emphasize start getting back to
a more open society's functional
societies
and rebooting our economies because it
is a severe cover disease which is
generating the fear
and it's the severe cover disease which
is uh
resulting in the loss of confidence and
and
whether it's in terms of individuals in
terms of employers
etc that underpin the economic
challenges we face
so what we look at is how much vaccine
do we need
to reduce the risk of severe disease and
as was described in the opening comments
of the director general
we have a better and better
understanding of who is
at most at risk of the disease and most
at risk
of severe cova disease so
we don't need vaccines for absolutely
everyone right at the very beginning
what we need to make sure
is as we've said before
all countries get some vaccine and that
we use that vaccine to protect our
health care workforce and care workers
and then to protect our elderly and then
protect the others who are at highest
risk
and that can be done initially with
relatively small quantities of vaccine
as they come out and then grow over time
so the important thing is not what is
the exact
number but how much vaccine do we need
at the beginning
to be able to reduce the risk of severe
disease because that's the key
to removing the fear of rebuilding the
confidence and getting our societies and
economies working again and the 200 plus
million doses would definitely go a long
way
to achieving that but right now we're a
very long way
even from that 200 million doses
so that's the key um it's been an
important week
and we're certainly encouraged by what
we're seeing
again in terms of a tremendous
solidarity to try and ensure we reduce
that
risk of the disease around the world and
start getting back to a more
normal way of functioning going forward
i think some you wanted to add
very briefly just to add i think bruce
has explained it very well
just to add that the african union has
taken
real leadership in this and
engaged with discussions with who but
also with
with other partners on making sure that
there's access
to vaccine the best vaccines
for the african people but also to be
part of the development
part of the research and development
process and so
the the strategy for the covet vaccines
for africa really has three pillars the
first one being
very much to be playing a leadership
role in the research and
and development of these vaccines
ensuring that clinical trials take place
in africa so that these vaccines are
tested in different
ethnic groups different racial groups
age groups etc so that you have
better estimates of how this vaccine
works in different populations
also focusing on expanding manufacturing
capacity
in africa getting into technology
transfer and so on this is building
capacity for the future
and of course focusing also on the
policy the implementation how delivery
of these vaccines will take place
as we know that you know many countries
face a lot of challenges in delivery
even of routine
vaccines to children and this is going
to be a vaccine that's going to be
have to be given to to other age groups
this is not a childhood vaccine so we're
going to
have to every country needs to start
thinking about
how these campaigns are going to be run
and what is going to be needed in terms
of
human resources you know supply chains
cold chain equipment
logistics needle syringes etc training
so that when the vaccine is available
that there's no delay in really in
launching these immunization
programs thanks
thank you dr swaminathan and thank you
bruce for your answer
i believe mike ryan has something to add
mike can you hear me
yes i'm just
speaking with specific reference to
africa
and to colleagues in africa sorry mike
you are very soft can you speak out
please
speak up thank you
try again mike thank you hello
speak a bit louder or maybe increase
your volume i'm
i'm taking the
uh i can't i can't speak any louder than
otherwise i'm shouting so
yeah can you hear me now you are great i
think go ahead
i just wanted to reflect on the
contribution that
african countries have made in general
to vaccination and to recongratulate
africa as a continent for the
eradication of polio and the
certification of that
eradication a huge task carried out with
you know many many
many years of effort and and both uh ted
ross
in ethiopia and uh already uh dr wetty
and bruce himself was sitting there
championed a lot of the the work that
led to that but also in the areas of
cholera and the areas of meningitis and
the urival of fever and ebola
african countries have championed a lot
of the techniques we use now for mass
vaccination
for community engagement um and and for
really going after infectious diseases
particularly these epidemic diseases
so africa has a lot to also share with
the world it's not
just a beneficiary in this process
africa has
learned the techniques of introducing
new vaccines of introducing new vaccines
quickly against epidemic diseases
and in in innovating in terms of
implementation in terms of logistics
and again dr tedros spoke to the
situation of ebola
it was african health workers african
scientists who worked
to bring the ebola vaccine into the
field a vaccine that had to be
transported at minus 80 degrees
into the deep field and given with very
stringent oversight and
and data gathering and safety measures
and again a huge triumph for african
public health so
in this i believe african countries and
particularly african scientists and
african doctors and nurses
have a lot to tell the world about how
we can introduce
a vaccine against covenant in an
effective way
and outscale thank you thank you dr
ryan there is no other intervention in
the room i would like to give the floor
now
to peter schilling from the european
news agency peter can you hear me
indeed thank you can you hear me yeah
very well go ahead please with all the
schools opening up in most of the
european countries now there's a very
big debate
what to do and how to handle children i
want to refer to a publication that was
made by the manchester the
massachusetts general hospital and the
child hospital
that provided critical data showing an
alarming
twist with children that they likely
play a much
bigger role in spreading the coronavirus
than we actually thought so far
so also that they were having a very
high viral load
so the question is to what extent should
we then go
through lockdowns when a class is
identified with having a covit
19 infection should we actually lock
down
or should we contain the children in
class
for the period otherwise they go back
home and be
spreading it more than we thought thank
you
thank you peter dr maria yes thank you
peter for
this really important question so um you
highlight a study
uh that has been recently published and
in fact there are a number of studies
uh now that are looking at um three
major
important aspects of coven 19 in
children
one is the severity of disease the
disease that is
experienced by children and adolescents
and luckily
most children have mild disease many
children have asymptomatic infection
it's not universal we do have reports of
children having
severe disease and some children have
died
the second thing we look at as is the
extent of infection
among children we've known from the
beginning and we have said repeatedly
that children can be infected with the
sars cov2 virus
and of course they can all people are
susceptible to this virus
what we didn't understand and what we
are starting to learn is is the extent
of infection among children this is
captured mainly through these cereal
epidemiology studies
and there are several studies now that
have been published that look
at the age differences among and
seroprevalence
what is important when we look at
infection rates is we we need to break
the children down by age group
um because there seems to be different
rates of infection as measured by these
antibodies in the youngest
children with lower levels of rates of
infection or seroprevalence
compared to so they can be infected
the third thing that we look at um is
transmission
and are children capable of transmitting
the virus
and again from the beginning we knew
that
children committing the virus we learned
this very early on from household
transmission studies
that were conducted in the early days in
china um
and what we were really concerned about
in the beginning was were children
infecting adults or adults infecting
children
and we knew and we know that
transmission can happen both ways
although in the beginning a period it's
more often happening transmitting from
adults to children
what we're learning about now is that
again it's very
sensible to look and it's important to
look at age differences in children
because there are different contact
patterns among children
so in terms of transmission the youngest
children tend to transmit less
and if you just look at the type of
contact patterns that they have and
their ability to transmit
but adolescents do transmit and they can
transmit the virus and they seem to
transmit
at similar rates to adults so it's
important when you consider
what to do with children and that was
your question
you treat all people we look at
different age groupings
when we think about schools and we think
about opening up schools
you've heard us say many many times that
is important that we don't
look at schools in isolation schools are
part of communities and if the virus is
transmitting
communities it can transmit in that
school but
there is some importance to
making conditions when schools are open
for the youngest children compared to
adolescents
we've outlined a series of
considerations and guidance
around how schools could open up safely
everybody recognizes the incredible
importance of schools
not only for education but for security
for in some situations
for food and for their social and their
mental well-being
and so it's very important to consider
the type of school
the age group that's there and the
grades their ability to comply
and adhere to public health measures
like physical distancing
the wearing of masks where appropriate
hand hygiene
all of the different factors that are
part of opening up society safely and
opening up schools
is included in opening up societies
safely so we're learning a lot
um but i do think it's important we
don't know everything as it relates to
children
but there are a lot of good studies that
are out there and i think we all
recognize the importance of keeping
children safe
but it starts with the community
bringing transmission in control
in the communities is critical all of
the individual
measures that you need to take to
protect yourself whatever age you are
from getting infected and prevent you
from passing to another
is really important hand hygiene
respiratory etiquette wearing a mask
where appropriate
all of that in addition to active case
finding isolation of cases contact
tracing
all of this needs to be as part of
our new normal as we go forward
thank you dr maria we have now
a question from bien kumar from india
biz news connect kumar can you hear me
kumar yeah you hear me
yes uh very well go ahead please yeah
yeah
see uh my question comes from the
experience in india
uh for a long time many leaders
politicians have been
saying claiming that uh you know by the
year end or relapse next year will have
a vaccine
safe vaccine etc and on the other hand
we have a group of doctors
questioning that you know not to make
false promises or to create false
aspirations among the people about the
vaccine
my question is what
how realistic is to
assume that the vaccine will be
available soon six months eight months
what kind of period that we can look at
because it is carrying a lot of
confusion in the minds
thank you kumar i think this is a
question for dr swaminathan
sumiya please
thank you for that question
as you know there are a large number of
clinical trials going on
worldwide we have more than 30
candidates now in clinical trials about
nine of them are in phase three clinical
trials
um there are at least three clinical
trials going on in india
um phase one and two uh
trials so um it's it's a very optimistic
scenario because there's a huge field of
candidates and we know that normally in
vaccine development
we expect about 10 success rate
and so to have more in in the early
stages of testing
gives us hope that several of them would
uh
be able to be you know prove themselves
to be safe and efficacious
as we said earlier these need to go
through the full phase three clinical
trials
before we we can answer that question
we expect results from some of the
candidates which are
already in phase three trials to come by
the end of the year or the beginning of
next year
following which there will have to be
scaling of manufacturing
to produce the hundreds of millions of
doses
that are going to be needed in fact the
world is going to need
billions of doses and that's going to
take time to manufacture
so we have to be optimistic and
realistic
at the same time so realistically
speaking
uh probably the second half of the
middle of 2021 uh maybe the second
quarter third quarter of 2021 is when we
can start seeing doses actually flowing
into countries
so that they can start immunizing their
populations
and as we as bruce was saying earlier
we're not going to have enough for the
whole world you know right at the
beginning we're going to see first
tens of millions of doses then hundreds
of millions of doses
and subsequently hopefully that scale up
will happen
so eventually there will be enough
everyone but it
will mean prioritization prioritization
of groups within countries who should
receive those first
tranches of vaccines and this is where
the kovacs
facility and the fair allocation
framework that's been developed by wa
in in consultation and agreement with
our member states
would play an important role in
determining
how those scarce doses of vaccines in
the beginning
will be distributed and used hopefully
in a fair and equitable manner so that
as the dg was saying earlier
it is important to make sure that the
people who need the vaccines get it
regardless of which countries they're
living in there's no point some
countries vaccinating entire populations
while
others are waiting for a long time so
that's what the kovacs
initiative and the kovacs facility uh
aims to achieve
and and if it comes sooner the better
but certainly by the middle of 2021 uh
we should start seeing some
some vaccines actually moving into
countries and into populations
maybe bruce wants to add
thanks if i just may add one thing i
just to supplement what sumia was saying
about the advancement of the
the vaccines i just want to make it
crystal clear
there's so much that we can do now while
the vaccines
are being accelerated and being
developed and it's been outlined very
clearly that
it's a safe and effective vaccine that
is is so much of the world is working
towards
and that's really wonderful but there's
so much that you can do now
and i think we will hammer this as much
as we possibly can
because there are individual steps that
you as an individual can take
to protect yourself from getting
infected to minimize
your exposure to manage your risk this
has to do with how you live your daily
life and everybody wants to get back to
you know a normal life and get back to
what
used to be but we need to make
considered decisions
about how we go about doing that how we
go to work
you know if we need to wear a mask where
we can't physical distance
we need to practice hand hygiene and
respiratory etiquette
avoid the three c's you know these
crowded spaces and closed settings
especially with poor ventilation there
are ways in which you can minimize your
exposure
and to be informed so what is really
important is if that you know where the
virus
is in the areas where you live in areas
where you work
and this comes from the strong
government-led
responses that we are seeing in so many
countries the strong
clear response at a national level
implemented
at the local level what we are seeing
now is countries that
in the beginning many had to put in
these national lockdowns because
so-called lockdowns
um because they needed to buy themselves
some time to take the heat out of the of
the virus out of the out of the
transmission
and get some time to get their systems
on track many countries have a public
health workforce now
they have testing capacity that has been
greatly increased
they have contact tracers that are out
there that they're
preventing clusters from happening or
when clusters do happen
they're rapidly carrying out these
outbreak investigations
all of these things are really positive
and i just want to highlight this
because we are seeing many countries
apply these public health measures
and taking at great effort in bringing
outbreaks
under control and these are things that
are happening now so we need
a government strong government strong
government-led responses
we need very targeted tailored local
implementation
so that we can avoid national lockdowns
again and we are very hopeful and we are
seeing in many countries they're
applying
targeted time-bound geographically bound
measures
to bring outbreaks under control and
using all of the active case-finding
contact tracing
um training your workforce protecting
your workforce
improving clinical care getting
hospitals ready all of that is still
happening in the background
and countries that have been successful
in suppressing transmission
are ready they are ready to identify
cases very quickly they're ready to
identify clusters
and carry out the necessary steps to
prevent those clusters from becoming
community transmission
so i just want to emphasize that there's
so much that all of you are doing now
that is is benefiting society
and is helping this pandemic so please
you know be hopeful
and be empowered that you there's a lot
that you can do
i think dr bruce has something to add
bruce
yeah i i think just to help mr kumar
that was an important question i think
it's hard for the general public when
they're hearing these
um sometimes substantially different
assessments of how long it will take us
to actually have a successful vaccine
and if indeed these trials are
successful and sometimes it's helpful to
demystify these timelines a little bit
but if you think about these trials
these fit what you keep hearing phase
three trials
remember these involve tens of thousands
of people usually the
the large ones we really need to see an
effect of the vaccine on
you have to give people one dose and
then usually it's at least two weeks or
three or four weeks
before they get the second dose and by
the time you enroll that many people get
those two doses in that's
often three months or longer and and it
can't be shorter than two obviously but
it's usually a few months just to get
that many
enrolled in the trials and then you've
got to observe them for a long enough
period
to understand who is protected and not
protected so
and and there you're a little bit um at
the
at the mercy of the epidemic itself
because it depends on how much disease
is actually circulating in the community
by that point
and then when you finally have that
which will take a couple of months a few
months depending on the intensity of
transmission
then you've got to analyze those data
you've got to get the product license
now there's some things we can do to
speed things up we can
if we think it's a very promising
vaccine we can produce it
in parallel at risk even if it fails
we'd have to throw those doses away as
you've heard
um but there are other things you simply
can't speed up and this goes back to the
important question asked earlier
if i remember it was by anna i believe
about um you know the vaccine confidence
we can accelerate many parts of the
process and we'll work very very hard to
do that
scientists manufacturers everyone is
doing their best
but you cannot accelerate certain parts
which are essential to ensuring the
vaccines are safe
and efficacious that takes a certain
amount of observational time
that you simply can't rush and it would
be in no one's interest to rush that
part of it because that
is what would shatter the confidence and
trust which is so important in this
process
to roll out these vaccines so when you
stop and think a little bit
these phase three trials how big are
they they're going to give two doses up
to a month apart and then they're gonna
have to follow those people for some
time
you can understand why these timelines
can be fairly long between now and when
we have a definitive answer
and also some of the factors are simply
out of our control
because it will depend on how intense
transmission is in an area
thank you dr ellward i think we will
wrap up now the
press conference if there is no other
intervention in the room
maybe dr bente wants to add something
thank you thank you very much and and
thank you for
also focusing today on the chronic
diseases and of course the
primary task just now is to defeat covet
19.
but at the same time i think we cannot
ignore
as dr maria as well says that
we have to work to really
to treatment and we can see that cancer
diagnosis really are
suffering but also the landsat article
focusing on the universal health
coverage
uh tells us that we will not be able to
reach this without also including
non-communicable diseases
and the publication today from
the lancet imperial college double ho
and ncd alliance
show us that we need to work much harder
so i think
if i may add i think really to learn
from this
pandemic and build back better and we
cannot continue the same way because a
new pandemic
will again really also be
final words dr tedros thank you
thank you thank you fadila thank you for
moderating today and i would like
actually to use this opportunity to
thank
margareta for
moderating the past few months
and today is friday so
i wish you a nice weekend
and in this room we have i have many
colleagues here with me and
i just would like to introduce actually
the countries they come from
maybe i'll start from the moderator is
from algeria
and then i have australia canada poland
serbia india the united states
norway the united kingdom
lebanon afghanistan and netherlands
ireland france
and of course myself from ethiopia
so that's the diversity we have in the
in the bleacho and i'm really proud to
be doubleh
and it's the whole world which is
serving you
and thank you all for uh joining us
and please accept my our happy weekend
from all my colleagues representing
almost the whole world as i have just
read
where they come from we are the world
and national unity
and our solidarity is the antidote to
this pandemic
thank you so much again have a nice
weekend bye-bye and see you on monday
thank you all bye